[Música]
y es hora de conectar con la red de
corresponsales de france 24 en directo a
hoy vamos a caracas a donde se encuentra
daniela zambrano la ong venezolana
espacio público documento 244 casos de
violaciones a la libertad de expresión
en 2021 un 37 por ciento menos en
comparación al año anterior no obstante
la organización resalta que esto no
significa una mejora estructural en el
derecho a la libertad de expresión
daniela cuáles son las violaciones
documentadas por espacio público y
quiénes son los responsables
hola qué tal según este informe
divulgado por la ong espacio público el
70% de las víctimas de estos casos que
comentaban precisamente eran periodistas
y los otros tipos de violación era la
censura el hostigamiento y el
amedrentamiento a los periodistas así
como también 166 casos de intimidación
es los principales agresores son los
cuerpos de seguridad del estado y
funcionarios públicos que también
utilizan las redes sociales y los medios
de comunicación del estado precisamente
para hostigar y fustigar a los
periodistas también vale la pena
destacar que en este informe resaltaban
la detención no sólo de periodistas sino
de info ciudadanos durante el año 2021
el registro fue de 35 personas que
fueron detenidas bien sea por buscar o
por difundir información un patrón que
se mantiene durante el año 2022
recordemos que tan sólo a mediados del
mes de abril una señora de 72 años fue
detenida luego de publicar a través de
la red social tictoc una burla
con respecto a nicolás maduró y altos
funcionarios del gobierno esto le costó
una detención hoy en día está libre pero
tener régimen de presentación cada 30
días para ello se utilizó la ley del
odio una legislación que a juicio de las
organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos humanos y la libertad de
expresión es utilizada precisamente para
amedrentar intimidar no sólo a
periodistas sino también a particulares
daniela podemos decir que son frecuentes
las sanciones a estas plataformas
digitales
bueno llama la atención en la crecida en
cuanto a los bloqueos a las páginas web
en venezuela desde el año 2014 la
organización ve sin filtro ha registrado
que ha aumentado la censura en internet
con respecto a los medios digitales y
hay algo importante que prácticamente
hoy en día en venezuela si alguien
quiere informarse tiene que ser a través
de estos medios porque la mayoría de los
canales internacionales de noticias
fueron sacados del aire entre el año
2014 y el 2018 los periódicos físicos en
venezuela prácticamente son inexistentes
antes había más de 100 ahorita y menos
de 10 entonces las personas acuden
precisamente las plataformas digitales
para informarse y en la organización ve
sin filtro registraba durante el año
2021 59 bloqueos a páginas web 45 de
ellos tenían que ver con medios de
comunicación este es una censura que
aplica conatel el ente regulador que
obliga a los prestadores de servicios
precisamente bloquear estas páginas esto
hace que hoy día en venezuela sea muy
difícil para un ciudadano informar se
tiene que instalar bp en es en sus
computadoras para poder acceder acceder
a estas páginas porque prácticamente
todos los canales
nacionales de noticias lo que hacen en
su mayoría de reproducir propaganda del
gobierno